hi I'm Naomi from the planet Coast
project and I'm here to tell you how
great our coast is and how you can stay
safe on the beach inflatables are not
designed for the sea you can't see the
bottom then it's really hard to tell how
deep it is even what nasties might be
lurking beneath do you think all and its
beaches have lifeguards on them in the
summer only some of the beaches are
patrolled by lifeguards here in family
so we use flags to help you leave safe
if you anyone else is in trouble at the
beach ask for help many of us have these
and if you do have one you need to take
it with you when you go out because if
someone gets in trouble you can dial 999
and ask for the Coast Guard
another organization than the safdar
safety on the coat is the royal national
lifeboat institute or they are in a life
for sure many people confuse the Coast
Guard the lifeguards and the RNLI and
this is probably because we work so
closely together to take up swimming
lessons will join a life saving club I
need your help to look after our
environment team I'm not the only one